except the devil said about taking a
knife in the heart of people did you
know sir sir you must allow them the
flecks of fancy its dreary in the north
everybody is Charlie this is going to be
my episode 3 Q&A video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet overall there were really just a
couple big things that most people were
talking about in the comments you know 1
what was going on with brand what was up
with Jon Snow and Daenerys what was
going on with the battles and what was
going on with the timelines so I won't
do a whole lot of timeline explaining
because yes the timelines do not make
sense at all in reality the episodes
aren't happening one day right after the
other like it takes a long time for
Euron to sail all the way around from
King's Landing after this scene right
here and destroy the unsullied fleet at
Casterly Rock it would take them weeks
to sail all the way around Westeros
using Iran as an example it's really
easy to chart his timeline like he
dropped the sand snakes off then he
sailed for a couple weeks around
destroys the unsullied fleet the thing
that doesn't make sense is how all this
is happening in the same episode so like
the stuff we're seeing on Dragonstone
isn't happening at the same moment in
time as the stuff over at Casterly Rock
is happening but they're both in the
same episode so it gets really confusing
so I feel your timeline pain I try to
ignore it that's why I didn't include
too many specific time line questions in
this I tried to stick to stuff mostly
from episode 3 but there were a lot of
episode 4 questions - here we go Marya
asks why do you think that jon was so
weird about Davos telling Danny that he
died and came back why didn't melt a
Sandra tell her about that so yeah this
is one of the biggest questions that I
got in the comments I think the idea is
that he feels like that's asking too
much of her like this is a really big
deal that we're trying to come together
and I don't want to freak you out see
100% totally valid criticism of this in
the way that it's written is because
Daenerys has three dragons she spends a
great deal of their conversation hyping
them up the most big supernatural WTF
things on the show she doesn't bat an
eyelash at that
but somehow coming back from the dead is
too much like she literally was reborn
in the fire even though technically she
didn't die so she and John both have
that in common
we were reborn and kissed by fire John
being kissed by the red God not
literally fire like Daenerys the best
way to tackle stuff like this is just to
look at the shows intent like okay
they're trying to show that Jon Snow
feels like he's going to overwhelm
Daenerys and he's only just learning
about the Dragons now so maybe he
doesn't fully understand what she's
comfortable with and what she's not so I
would recommend not poking too deep into
big illogical like that because it'll
just make you matter next one
Brandon asks hey Charlie do you think
they look at a tourney at Harrenhal
flashback I want to see Rhaegar so I
still 100% believe that we're going to
see a version of Rhaegar this season but
now I'm kind of backing off the
Harrenhal flashback after the way they
treated flashbacks last season I was
like okay you know contextually they
need to explain Rhaegar and Lyanna like
they gave us a teaser now they need to
show a version of that on screen so
tourney at Harrenhal be an easy way to
do that Littlefinger has referred to it
in the past Barristan Selmy has even
referred to it and he had that whole big
story about him singing with Rhaegar
down in King's Landing
so they mentioned a character so many
times eventually they have to show him
to pay that up
so yes Rhaegar but now based on the way
they're brushing over stuff super
quickly I do not think that they spent
the time or the money to do a full-blown
turning Harrenhal flashback so whatever
version of a Rhaegar scene we end up
seeing I'm expecting it to be about as
big or long as the Tower of joy scene at
the end of the season last year next one
Erik asked do you think that Melisandre
referenced what Varys heard in the
flames when she said he will die in this
country he was taken aback by it yeah
that's definitely a good theory and it's
totally possible but I think based on
the way the characters written this
season he was more taken aback by it
because it's just a WTF thing to say to
somebody oh I'll be back because I'm
meant to die in this strange land as are
you Varys so all she's really saying in
that is that she's sort of foreseen that
she's going to die in the war for the
dot or she senses that she's destined to
die and she's made her peace with that
but the other characters haven't come to
terms with that because they haven't
been thinking about it at all they've
only been thinking about the war with
Cersei so I think that's mostly why you
get that Varys reaction but as for what
the voice in the flame said to him I do
think that it was one of those moments
like the Hound had
where he saw a vision and he didn't
fully understand it but you have to
remember that this is when he was a
child so I don't know if the show's ever
actually going to pay that off that
feels like it would be a Tyrian
conversation next one GD geo asks isn't
Braavos a city built by slaves isn't
Braavos a city where people despise
slavery but the iron bank of Braavos
makes money with slavery in Essos so
yeah you're talking about what taiko and
the stores was saying he implies that
they've lost money because of Daenerys
most of you probably know at least a
little bit about the founding of the
city of Braavos after the fall of the
Valyrian freehold a bunch of slaves
basically ran away to this area where
Braavos was founded they hid out they
made this hidden city and then
eventually later revealed themselves to
the rest of the world during that time
they flourished they founded the iron
bank but I think the implication here is
that the iron bank at this point only
cares about money so if it's something
that's going to make them a lot of money
they probably don't care about how taboo
it is the iron bank will have its due
there's nothing about morality that's
baked into that the iron bank will have
what belongs to it which is money
next one Xavier asks San has a lot of
documents to transcribe presumably
related to the book the archmaester is
writing about Robert's rebellion is that
how he's going to learn about Rhaegar
and Lyanna x' wedding so you're assuming
that they did get secretly married
there's a record of it somewhere in the
Citadel I do think that same mole is
going to learn about Jon Snow's
parentage in those documents regardless
of what Jon Snow's status is yes I do
think that Samwell is going to find the
other piece of information that will
prove the things that bran is saying
like there'll be a couple different
components to it
jon snow's son of Rhaegar Liana here
watch this play out on screen then the
legal proof of that will come from
Samwell on the Citadel and all the stuff
that he and Gilly are reading about next
one though Shawn asks was brand talking
about her wedding with Ramsay so you're
talking about when he was talking to
Santa about the white dress yes yeah
that was what everybody was freaking out
about like hey I watched this happen to
you you look really beautiful so I think
the idea is that he can't really
decipher a context from scenes like he
didn't recognize this was a horrible
night for her he just saw the wedding he
didn't see what happened later he didn't
see the rest of this moment didn't have
any context for what was really
going on so just be prepared for brand
to slowly learn more and make a lot more
errors in judgment as he tries to fight
the night king so if he can derp this
think about the other stuff he can turb
we haven't even talked about the idea
that he's broken the enchantment on the
wall in the show hasn't even really
addressed it so be prepared for
something really bad to happen with
brands storyline next one a bonanno asks
do you think that Daario and the second
sons will still have a part to play in
the big war if Danny keeps losing armies
could Gendry own Daario beat together
right now you definitely think that
Daario is nowhere near Gendry Daario
still in the east Melisandre is going
back to the east though remember during
season six
Daenerys left Daario in charge of marine
but it sounds like the situation with
the slavers is going to deteriorate
without the Dragons and the giant army
on their doorstep they'll probably try
to reboot the slave trade but if
Melisandre is going to volantis and she
said she's coming back she might come
back with more red priests to help in
the war for the dawn that would be the
opportunity for him to hop a ride with
them whether or not he's ever going to
come back but I don't think that there's
like any grander significance to his
return in the story other than just
being another person that controls a
group of people that could help out next
one rahul asks there's actually a couple
ones here why did bran not tell Santa
about John's parentage why did bran not
warn Santa about Littlefinger in what
are the documents that she's reading so
those first two parts I would say that
probably mostly for plot reasons like
they don't want to reveal that
information prematurely so that you know
complain against the show logic
overdramatic twist that's kind of a
recurring thing with the show how come
this character didn't give this very
critical information to this other
character you could say because bran
needs to learn to see clear so he
doesn't fully understand the information
himself but that's the most logical way
that I could think to explain that but
as for the last one I actually mixed my
time lines up so maester Luwin was
actually dead before the Bolton's came
along so there are a couple better
theories that I've seen that I like a
little bit better so one is that maester
Luwin has some record that has something
to do with Jon Snow but the better
theory I think is that it's something
that's a callback to season one because
the show's been doing that you see Arya
reunite with Nymeria for the first time
since this moment in season 1 you feel
lot of references to the people that
have died when they went south starts
don't fare well when they go south so
remember what happened during season one
when they were getting ready to behead
Ned Stark they made Santa declared that
her father was a traitor in send letters
to a bunch of different people one of
those letters was sent to Winterfell and
Robb Stark so there would be a letter of
sanso declaring that her father's a
traitor and she's loyal to the
Lannisters in the crown so that would be
a big piece of ammunition that
Littlefinger could use against Sansa so
if he sensed that she was moving against
him or making some sort of plot he could
try to threaten her with blackmail so
just a theory but I do feel like that's
the most relevant thing for Sansa
storyline and it feels like all the
little finger stuff that's happening
this season is revolving around her
character so whatever the big twist is
with these letters is probably something
specific to what she's done in what
Littlefinger's done next one Brad asks
do you think there'll be a reunion
between Jorah Mormont and a little bear
so you say yeah everybody's coming
together by the end of the season maybe
we'll get a bring Union I don't think
that's going to be the case right now
I'm expecting Jorah to be relatively
close to Daenerys I'm not expecting to
near us to go anywhere near Winterfell
although I do think that she's going to
go to the north like I think she's going
to have something to do with this big
final battle but I think the only way
that Jorah and the little bear wind up
in the same room or if Daenerys and the
little bear are in the same room and I
don't think that's going to happen but
thank you so much for submitting
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do especially trying to figure out
the timelines there will be more bonus
videos this week before episode 4 post
so if you want me to do anything
specific just let me know that'll
probably be in a couple days they'll be
some more Rick and Morty there's also
some more comic book stuff that just
drops I'll try to get through all that
stuff but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner core low you win an HBO
now subscription please private message
me so I can get your contact details
while you wait for everything click here
for the trailer for next week's episode
and you can click here for my episode 3
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you